we believe this virus is highly
infectious
uh we need to get more data to confirm
this but it seems to be much more
infectious than delta which of course is
problematic
and we also believe that it's already
present in most countries given the
large number of mutations it is highly
possible that the efficacy
of a vaccine all of them is going down
but we need to wait for the data to know
if this is true and how much is it going
down i believe it's going to take two to
six weeks to really know and i think we
need to be cautious that it could be
more virulent
it could be as virulent or it could be
less virulent and i think today it's
really impossible to know
i think all immigrants have concern for
several reasons right but there are a
lot of unknown things right now and keep
in mind that we have been preparing for
something like that for months
uh and um what is the playbook the
playbook it is to understand a little
bit better and then within weeks i think
we will know most of the information
that needs to be known but
every day you learn more so i'm very
very very confident that
this
drug
works for all known mutations including
the omicron one but we are working on
follow-up
drugs uh for the eventual case that
maybe a resistance is developed
sky science correspondent thomas moore
says the omicron variant's many
mutations suggest new vaccines will be
needed
on paper it doesn't look good look there
are 32 of the 50 mutations in this
variant are in the spike protein that's
the bit that's on the surface of the
virus and it is the the target for for
the vaccines and with so many mutations
the hunch is that it will reduce the
effectiveness how much and whether that
matters we don't know until we see real
world evidence because it's perfectly
possible that there are enough
antibodies left that are still working
particularly after the booster
that there would be enough there to at
least stop the hospitalizations and
deaths and clearly that is the most
important uh as as we move forward but
if the manufacturers do have to go back
to the drawing board reformulate their
their vaccines to take on this new
adversary well it's not the end of the
world we're not back at step one because
they know how to make a vaccine against
this virus it would take them about a
hundred days but then after that they
already have the regulatory framework
with the authorities they know what
they're dealing with it's a relatively
small change in the genetic sequence
that they'd need to look at and then of
course they have the manufacturing
capacity now to make huge volumes of
doses and we we know that modern are
pretty confident even if they are back
to the drawing board they would be able
to make a billion doses uh by the summer
of next year so not all bad news even if
we have to go back and redesign the
vaccine